I think the most important thing about
an astronaut is,
is you know,
you have to take for first of all,
take for a given.
That's a person's done pretty well at
school,
you know,
has a,
has the intelligence and all that to,
to learn new systems and new things.
Uh,
but after that,
the most important thing I think is
being able to get along with others,
you know,
flexibility and teamwork,
uh,
those issues because as we get flight
longer and longer and space,
those,
those are really important factors.
Even on short shuttle missions.
You know,
those are important factors to put a
crew together that can work together
effectively as a team that can get
along.
And so I think for an individual,
um,
you know,
I think the most important thing is
being able to work with others.
You know,
NASA interest,
stealing hadn't done that much until
fairly recently because we'd always
flown short missions and we're all
professionals and,
and,
uh,
the thinking as well,
you know,
everyone get along for a,
two week mission,
right?
And so,
and everyone can,
so it hasn't really been a problem.
The Russians had been flying long
duration cruise since the early
seventies.
And in the early days they've ended at
least two missions early because of
conflicts within the crew.
So they learned early on the importance
of studying this and making sure you put
the right crew together.
Uh,
since our,
we began our work together on the
international space station with the
Russians in the,
um,
you know,
early,
early two thousands.
We've started to,
NASA has started to learn the importance
of this kind of work.
And so NASA is looking much more into it
and funding more work into this,
uh,
through both directly by NASA as well as
through the NSP Ri.
And so I think it's important work and
we are now fully on board and
recognizing that it's important
[inaudible].